للمزيد ينضم الينا من اسطنبول مراسل
لفرونس 24 اسد اهلا بك حسين تركي هددت
مرارا باجتياح الشمال السوري لتحديد خطر
المقاتلين الاكراد هل يمكن ان تتحول هذه
الضربات الجويه الى عمليه بريه شامله في
شمال سوريا
وتتحدث عن امكانيه ان تتحول هذه ضربات
الجويه والمدفعيه الى عمليه بريه واسعه
نطاق تشمل الاهداف التركيه الجديده في
كوباني وتل رفعت ومنبج ولكن الامر مرتبط
بتصريحات الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان
لدى عودته من قطر ما الذي سيقرره الرئيس
التركي هل هذه الضربات الجويه كافيه كرد
على اعتداء همم اسطنبول الذي تتهم تركيا
حسب العمال الكردستاني وتحديدا وحدات
الحمايه في كوباني باصدار الاوامر لشنه ام
ان الامر
للتحديدات التي سمعناها مرارا وتكرارا على
لساني اردوغان خلال شهور الماضيه بشان
عمليه واسعه نطاق لتطهير المنطقه الحدوديه
ودفع المقاتلين الاكراد الى عمق يتجاوز
ثلاثين كيلو مترا في الحدود التركيه
السوريه بعد ان
لم تلتزم الولايات المتحده وروسيا
بتعهداتهما لتركيا بدفع المقاتلين الى ذلك
العمق
حسين كيف يتفاعل داخل التركيه مع هذه
العمليه العسكريه الجويه في تركيا لتركيا
في شمال سوريا والعراق لا سيما حزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي
حزب الشعوب الديمقراطي موقفه واضح هو يقف
بالظبط من الحرب واليوم دعى انصاره الى
الخروج والتجمع في العاصمه انقره عند
الخامسه هي التوقيت المحلي
لرفض له هذه العمليه العسكريه والدعوه الى
انهائها فورا صلاح الدين ده مرتاح الزعيم
السابق لحزب الشعوب الديمقراطيه المعتقل
منذ عام 2016 نشرت تغريده قال فيها ان ما
يجري هو استغلال سياسي سيئ لحاله همم
الغضب الشعبيه التي همم جاءت بعد انفجار
تقسيم ويقول ان السلطات التركيه تقطع
الطريقه امام التحقيق لظهور الحقائق في
هذا همم الاعتداء اللي تمطر الاكراد
بالقنابل يتحدث عن شمال سوريا وقال مره
اخرى ان الحسبه يقف بالظبط من الحرب بينما
اذا ما نظرنا الى وسائل الاعلام مقربه من
الحكومه فهي تصف الامر بانه همم انجاز
كبير تدمير لمواقع الارهابيين تدمير لجذور
الارهاب وايضا بالنسبه للاحزاب الداعمه
لحكومه اردوغان تتحدث بذات النبره وهي ان
هذه العمليه عمليه ل همم ضمان الامن
القومي وللرد على هجوم تقسيمه بالتالي الى
الان هناك انقسام وهو انقسام عاده ما كنا
نشهده خلال جميع العمليات السابقه التي
شنتها تركيا ضد المقاتلين الاكراد في
عفرين وفي ايضا في همم تل ابيض شكرا جزيلا
لك على كل هذه التفاصيل حسين اسد وراسل
الفرنسي اسطنبول